Peter Grant: Well, over the last 40 years,
since the time we started our Galapagos research
there have been two or three major changes
in general understanding of how evolution
works.
The first is a big development in computer
technology which has allowed people to analyze
large quantities of data.
And the second one is a very large development
in molecular genetics, which has given many
biologists the tools to examining evolution
at genetic level.
And the third one is the field studies that
have been done that allow people to understand
just how rapidly evolution takes place.
Not over centuries, not over decades, but
over a short period of time such as a year
for organisms as large as birds.
Rosemary Grant: The general theory of evolution
has changed very little.
What actually has changed are the techniques
that allowed us to study it.
And one of the biggest ones is the genetic
techniques.
So now that we are able to sequence whole
genomes, we've been able to look at the genes
that are responsible for some of the changes
that we have seen in the field.
So this has been been extremely exciting.
And so it is more that we are able to go in
depth to a much greater degree than they were
before.